Ein gewöhnlicher Mittag am
Bahnhof Zoo.
Obdachlose warten vor der
Bahnhofsmission auf kostenloses Essen,
eine Dusche oder einen neuen Haarschnitt.
Einmal pro Woche schneidet die gelernte
Friseurin Franziska Dinter
ehrenamtlich die Haare.
Aber nur um die Frisur geht es hier nicht.
Eigentlich brauchen viele von denen bloß
jemand[en], der sie in den Arm nimmt
oder der sie … und der Zeit hat und zuhört
und einfach mal führt, ja?!
Und sie sind … manche Leute, die sagen
dann Mama zu mir, oder:
Ach, wenn ich jetzt … wenn du doch
meine Mutter wärst,
dann würde ich ganz anders leben.
Draußen riecht es nach Urin,
Schnaps und Schweiß,
drinnen in der Friseurecke von Franziska
Dinter nach Haarschaum und Pflegecreme.
Manche Kunden haben sich
lange nicht gewaschen,
stinken, andere haben sogar Läuse.
Also, geekelt habe ich mich vor gar keinem.
Ich hab' literweise schon Desinfektionszeug
quasi verbraucht.
Ich hab' da keinen Ekel davor.
Ich muss bald wieder ins Krankenhaus.
Ach du je! Ernsthaft, oder… ?
Ja, ernsthaft.
Ich lag ja schon einmal im Koma.
Was?
Ja!
Früher arbeitete Anselm als Journalist,
doch dann wurde er krank, verlor seinen
Job, vor drei Jahren die Wohnung.
Zum Abschluss schenkt Franziska
Dinter ihm Sorgenpüppchen,
ihnen soll er seine Nöte erzählen,
wenn sie nicht da ist.
Und du hast ja immer ein liebes
Wort für die Leute,
die auch dich teilweise gar nicht
verstehen. Darf ich dich umarmen?
Ach, na gerne. Na, da wünsch ich dir
alles Gute.
Und dir auch alles Gute!
Das war für mich immer schon 'ne Freundin.
Also, ich gehe da nicht hin, weil ich
kostenlos den Haarschnitt bekommen kann,
sondern die guten Gespräche mit ihr.
Und das ist so ‘n Geben und Nehmen.
Dieser Rucksack und sein Stoffschaf
sind sein einziger Besitz.
Auch Franziska Dinters Leben stand
schon auf Messers Schneide.
Früher hatte sie ein eigenes Häuschen
mit ihrem Mann und ihren zwei Kindern.
Ein schwerer Autounfall änderte alles.
Aus dem Schicksalsschlag hat sie gelernt.
Also, ich sage: Das Fallen ist schlimm,
das Liegenbleiben ist noch schlimmer,
aber das Nicht-Wiederaufstehen ist
am allerschlimmsten, nicht?
Ohne den Unfall, sagt sie, wäre sie
nie auf die Idee gekommen,
Obdachlosen ehrenamtlich die
Haare zu schneiden.
Ich bin dankbar, dass meine Hände heil
geblieben sind, und das ist meine Aufgabe,
und wenn der liebe Gott mir noch
ein paar Jahre gibt,
dann mache ich das noch so lange wie …
Franziska Dinter hat nachgerechnet:
Mehr als 11.000 Bedürftigen hat
sie schon die Haare geschnitten.
Und es können noch viele mehr werden.